all right good morning
can everyone hear me yeah um just say we
are ready to
um we'll be ready to start the meeting
in a short while when we have
confirmation the meeting is streaming
live to youtube
so just need to wait for that
confirmation
flat
um good morning and welcome to the
licensing
subcommittee all participants today are
taking part remotely
and we are now live streaming turn into
the agenda we have the appointment for
chairman
can i have a nomination please for the
chairman
i would like to nominate councillor john
nutley please
thank you councillor kurzweil do we have
a second uh
i'll second that councillor bradford
thank you
um that'll be if you're both in
agreement um
councillor nutley um i now hand over to
you as chairman thank you
thank you trish um good morning everyone
and welcome to
this morning's licensing meeting um
before proceeding through the agenda
remainder of the agenda i will make a
few introductions
can i please ask that you make sure all
microphones are muted
when not speaking to avoid any
background noise levels
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic blue hand
and wait to be called in
i'd like to introduce you to the
officers
debbie rosenweld who is our licensing
officer
marie downing solicitor trish corns
democratic services officer
beth tipton democratic service and legal
assistance
and jessica hogan environmental health
officer
members of the public participating
today are the applicant mr bishop
and two representatives of the parish
council linda bellshaw and pat moody
turning to the agenda agenda item three
the minutes uh proposer and second are
required to approve the minutes of the
last meeting
and the authority to sign at a later
date could i have a proposal please
thank you very much indeed um
yeah item item four on the agenda
declarations of interest
to any to either of you i have no
interest myself do you either review
anything in your interest
no thank you very much indeed moving on
to item five
local government access to information
act 1985
exclusion of present public i don't
think that's going to be required today
so we move on to item six um finger gang
golf club
application for a premises license
variation
we have a matter to consider this
morning which is an application
for a variation in respect of finger
glenn golf club
golf hotel ted burton mary the licensing
officer will present the report
attached to the agenda clarifying any
points arising
she does not make any recommendations to
the subcommittee
the legal advisor will give evidence
will give advice
on questions of law practice procedure
and assist the subcommittee in recording
the reasons for the decision
the legal advisor may attend the
subcommittee
when we withdraw to consider our
decision but only to give legal and
procedural advice
the decision we make the decision we
make is whether
sorry the decision we make is whether or
not to grant the application in full
or in part and whether if granted
any further conditions should be imposed
in addition to the mandatory conditions
exact wording depends on the application
type
andrea and marie will obviously check on
this further
we will reach this decision based on the
merits of the application and with a
view of promoting
the four licensing objectives we will
have regard to the council's licensing
policy statement
the secretary of state's guidance and
the nature of the
representations and responsible
authorities and interested parties
we will adjourn the meeting to make a
decision on the application
we will reconvene the meeting had to
announce a decision
during the adjournment the live
streaming of the meeting
to youtube will be stopped and restarted
when we
when the meeting is reconvened to
announce the decision
i will now invite the legal advisor to
introduce the procedures up for the
meeting
marie thank you thank you chairman good
morning everybody
so the procedure today will be as
follows we will start with the licensing
officer who will outline the application
the subcommittee may ask questions of
the licensing officer
and interesting parties will also be
invited to ask questions of the
licensing officer
following this the objective
spokesperson will be invited to address
the hearing
for a maximum of 15 minutes included in
the 15 minutes there's also an
opportunity for a summary to be given
objectors for whom the spokesperson is
speaking on behalf of may be invited
to add any issues that haven't been
covered by the spokesperson
and today we have environmental health
as a relevant authority
and objectives from the parish council
so the order will be that the
environmental health officer
will make her representations first
followed by the parish council
representatives after
we've heard from all these parties and
everybody has not had an opportunity to
ask each other questions
we will then hear for the applicant
um the applicant may be asked questions
by committee members and may also be
asked questions by
other relevant parties the the procedure
really is that everybody gets their
opportunity to speak
and that every other party also has an
opportunity to ask questions
of the person who is speaking um
following this um the object will have
the opportunity to sum up
and it's the applicant who gets the
opportunity
to address the committee prior to their
retiring to make their decision
so if everybody's happy and clear with
the procedure
um don't worry i'll i'll let you know
when it is your turn to speak if you're
unsure
um we'll start then so debbie if you'd
like to address the committee please
okay okay good morning everybody thank
you marie
um we're here this morning to consider
an application for
variation of a premises license for
fingal glenn
golf hotel details are set out in the
report
but briefly the application is to extend
the times of the opening hours the sale
of alcohol
regulated to entertainment and the also
an addition of late-night refreshments
the only additional information i have
is that all of the representations apart
from one
are from pathfinder village residents
chair and committee are asked to
determine this application
thank you
thank you debbie so um at this time have
any of the members got
any questions for the licensing officer
not at the moment thank you
thank you have any of the other parties
at this time got a question for the
licensing officer
okay thank you so we'll move on now to
the
representations that have been made and
we start with the relevant authority
so today we've got jess hogan who is the
environmental health officer for team
bridge
so jess if you'd like to address the
committee please
good morning everyone thank you murray
um so
in regards to the proposed extension and
the opening times which would permit
the club to open until at least 2 a.m
every friday and saturday
and open from 7 a.m um i would agree
with the um
comments made from um the other
representatives
um from the parish council and um
also um residents of pathfinder village
um as opening until 2 a.m
is likely to cause um a noise
disturbance
um to residents of pathfinder village a
village
and the residents either side of um
single
glen club and residents of the woodlands
and with extension uh permitting the
extension
um would um
particularly give rise to um potential
um
you know uh noise kind of concerns
um and um customers would wouldn't have
left the club
um until at least half too um i feel the
change
um isn't necessary um
unless um we could obviously look at
something um in terms of um
putting a condition within the license
that would
um permit um that would be in within the
best interests
of residents within the vicinity of the
golf club
um to add the condition to the license
um this may
be in the form of a seasonal or event
variation where the hours proposed and
the variation are only permitted
um when these events take place such as
the weddings or
events that have been proposed by the
applicants um
and um i would also propose that
my department and licensing as well be
contacted when these events are due to
take place
um if this can be considered
then i will look obviously then to
conducting some sound monitoring before
these events take place
and liaising with also the um
the applicants and managers at the golf
club
and just to monitor sound levels um
but um in terms of the um actual
application as it stands um i wouldn't
agree
that an extension to these hours and the
supply of alcohol
until half one in the morning and
recorded music um is advisable
um but um haven't discussed with my
colleagues in licensing
um we feel that it would be in the best
interest to actually look at applying a
condition to the
to um the single glenn golf club's
existing license
um to only allow these hours to be
permitted
for occasions and
seasonal during seasonal times
that's that's all from me thank you
thank you jess so have any of the
committee any questions for the
environmental health officer
not from me at any rate thank you uh yes
i do
um thank you that that was very succinct
but um when you said um for
special occasions you know have an
extension
um and then you said unseasonal reasons
um are you meaning sort of
april to october and over christmas
or you know i mean are you doing a
blanket like that because
you know that's quite a long time a
season is a long time
um and i just want to be sure that um
i understand exactly how long you're
talking about
thank you for your comments um no i can
i can appreciate that
um it was um just something that was
brought up
and having discussed with my colleagues
in licensing
um so something similar was um put
in conditions um in another
establishment
um where a period of from uh
june to september they were allowed to
have events
um for um you know weddings or
um social gatherings things like that
but
it may be worth us considering that we
only
apply the conditions for each event we
also have
the facility for something called a
temporary event notice
um which is applied for
via licensing and then we get consulted
in environmental health
to see if we um agree with the
application
um but um from what i can understand
from the applicant's point of view
there's only an allowance for the amount
um for a certain amount
of temporary event notices to be um
issued per year
um so that would be um slightly
restrictive
if there were a number of events or
weddings
and things like that planned so it's
just finding a way to work around that
within the conditions of the license
to see um how would be best with to
liaise with the applicants
to see how they can let us know when
these events are happening
and for them for the events to happen
for them to contact us and give us more
information
um so that's just something that i would
propose really
um i hope that clarifies your question
um
but um yeah um
yeah thanks very much thank you
any further questions from members at
the moment
in that case um has the applicant got
any questions for the environmental
health
officer
hello hello everyone here you can hear
me that's good thank you
thank you jess um i appreciate your
comments
my only question is in regards to the
tens applications
is they are limited um
very limited to how many times you can
apply for those annually
and um it would be although it would it
would be fine for us to do it would
complicate
um and it wouldn't be
very consistent in what we can offer to
customers so would it not be better
to be have a formal licence which is
regulated by the conditions set out
by the council rather than having to
have make multiple applications to the
council for every single wedding
and or function that we had booked
thanks for that um no i i can appreciate
um you know obviously you have a limited
amount of um
temporary event notice that you can
actually apply for a year and that's why
i mentioned about the um
conditions within the license and so if
we can agree
um you know how often these events are
likely to happen
um during what times um you know times
of the year
um and um just a way for us to
keep open communication and liaise with
us
and so we know that when these events
are going to be happening
even if it is in terms of you know week
we get a phone call or
an email um just to let us know and
we can obviously look at um you know
um conducting some noise monitoring as
well setting
and noise parameters and things like
that before
these events are due to take place just
so they're at an acceptable level before
um you know before anything's agreed
really
it's just um making a tens application
for uh there seems to be a great focus
on
on the on when the uh the opening hours
and the sale of alcohol finishes but
referring to when it begins with you
know at the moment
um we're not able to offer um
for example a wedding party the
opportunity to have
a wedding breakfast where we can serve
alcohol
are we would we have to then apply for
tens notices
for a champagne reception at a wedding
i think that's just you know what i said
you know in terms of the tens
um if a separate condition could be
added to the license
just to say that it would be for um
you know events during a certain period
of time
or you know certain you know seasonal
yeah or certain months and things like
that but it's just something that we'd
have to agree
upon really um and look at
um but i can appreciate um
that you only have a limited amount of
times so yes
thank you thank you appreciate help
thank you thank you um has the license
officer got any further comments in
relation to anything we've heard so far
uh no no further comments thank you
thank you
okay um if we'll move on now to the
objectors so um
i understand one of you wishes to speak
so would you like to address the
committee now please thank you
hello i'm linda belshaw and i'm the
chair of ted bernstein mary parish
council
um i thought it might be helpful just to
set out a bit of
contextual um stuff around
this um finger glenn is to one side of
our parish
it's a golf course at the moment in open
countryside
uh with a number of um
um uh chalets i'm
trying to what they call them um
um to one side of the golf course um for
which there's been um
additional planning um um agreed for
further 25
to go to go out and next to the golf
course
um there's the park homes which is
called
pathfinder which are in a wooded area
and actually house about a third of our
parishioners about 400
homes there or residents um
who bought up right against the current
golf course
um this is a quiet rural setting um
other than um the park homes at
um pathfinder there are just a few
uh individual houses and a farm
quite um nearby the site
our concern as a parish is that we're
concerned about the noise
late at night i think specifically um
not daytime noise um pathfinder village
um has historically been um a site for
older people although that's somewhat
relaxed these days but most of the
residents are certainly over 50
and some are really quite elderly
and we're worried particularly about the
extension of
music and general sound of coming and
going from
the the lodges which i understand will
be about 50
uh lodges um when they're all built
um and we're particularly concerned
obviously about the
um application to have licensing until
um half past one on a friday and a
saturday
morning or the following morning
um currently um i understand from the
website
the golf course offers um meals and
um drinks until about nine at night
although i know
they um they have a license property to
stay open later than that
but basically the services are geared to
golfers
more recently understands that um
the um the golf membership has reduced
drastically
and no doubt partly as a response to
this um
there are um the owners of management
wish to
broaden their appeal to holidaymakers to
come in
into the site um but our concern is that
it now sounds like
this is well if this um application is
accepted
it will become more of a sort of
late-night party um
venue um which really concerns us
um the pathfinder homes uh um
some of them are only a few meters from
the lodges
on the single glenn's site um the
the rest of the village um
the village as a whole is is probably
about 100 meters from the clubhouse but
at times
noise carries more than sometimes when
it's quiet or in weather conditions the
noise carries more than at other times
um clearly we've had
objections have come in from a number of
residents
close to the site and we really um are
concerned
um for them in this um from
the change from what appeared to them to
be quite a quiet rural side to
something much more like um um a late
night holiday venue
um the other concern we have is that the
from time to time
um there have been um incidents that
thing again
where um we've needed um the residents
have
wished to report something that's
happening and they've not always find
found that there's management on site
that can deal with any
noise or disturbance late at night
obviously it's not always possible to
have
management there and indeed there's
something of a conflict i'm sure between
holiday makers who want to have a good
time
and people around to say please you know
don't make so much noise and i think
that
you know it's quite a difficult mix of
two groups of people wanting to do
entirely
different things so we are
worried about the effects on those
living to that side of pathfinder
village
who will be substantially affected by
this
i think i probably need to add as well
in view the um
comments from um environmental health
officer
that in actual fact probably the noise
nuisance is
um more accentuated in good weather
and in the summer and this time of year
when people are outdoors a lot more
especially if they're outdoors at their
lodges um in the hot tubs
and um or just enjoying themselves
outside
um so i'm not sure that that
would be a particularly good solution
but i myself would like to press for
um that events would be closed down
around about midnight on
the latest as a general thing
and i think the final point i'd like to
make as well that we do apply for tens
licenses for our village hall quite
regularly here
i think we're only allowed to do it
about 12 times a year um
for drama productions and parties and i
don't think we
best of my knowledge we've never been
granted anything beyond midnight
um so um this is the the village hall in
the main
part of temple and st mary that seems
something of a contradiction to us that
um if there was a different arrangement
um
in the same parish in a different part
of the parish
so i think that's all i want to say
thank you very much
thank you very much so have the members
any questions for the objector
yes thank you thank you uh right um
i i note i've seen we've had 12
objection letters coming in and you did
mention the
the new challenge etc i understand that
some of those are just about six meters
from one of the residents there um but
also
i know that um there's been a lot of
boisterous noise
unruly behavior i mean have you
witnessed this or
have you you know been told about this
by other residents at all
um i don't think this is extensive and i
think some of the difficulties were at
the beginning of the lockdown period
um i think again were kind enough to
make available some of their lodges to
key workers and to some other people and
i think
unfortunately there was some
disturbances around that
um but um i've certainly not heard
anything in the last couple of months
and i understand that the music can be
extremely loud i mean
have you witnessed that yourself or
anybody no i haven't personally
no okay thank you
counselor kurzweil or bradford would you
have any questions
no
[Music]
has the applicant got any question of
the objective just just some comments i
mean much of it i can
i cover in in the statement that i have
but i just just a few points we do have
a planning application for new lodges
but alongside that planning application
or as part of that planning application
we were
strengthening substantially a lot of the
gulf sides of the business as a
as a as a main focus almost um which
just leads to that the fact that goldfat
finger glenn is still our main focus it
is
our main business and alongside the
planning we do still have
many other strategies to strengthen our
membership base
and we we absolutely do not um
foresee the future leading to us being a
late night party venue
rather than a golf course golf course
has always been
here for 30 years and it will continue
to be the main focus with our membership
base
and our golfers will pay week in week
out
you mentioned um that you mentioned the
cabins a lot
um but the activity between the
clubhouse and the cabins most of the
time
is separate most of the time the lodges
are there with holiday makers
and people who are away on breaks and
it's only the
you know sometimes where we have
weddings that stay in some of the lodges
where there is a link at all
um so any you know increasing and late
night driving back to the lodges or or
indeed using
the lodges afterwards um wouldn't be
greatly affected too much because those
lodges are being used by holiday makers
most of the time
and not necessarily sole use to the
people that are having the parties or
the functions
the um alongside the planning
now i will i do comment on it in my
statement but we have issued
uh and will strengthen if need be a code
of conduct
and occupation for the people that use
those lodges
so that they are considerate to our
neighbors they they abide by the rules
that we set
in terms of how much noise they can make
from their lodge for example
no recorded music from their own lodge
or
no use of the hot tubs after a certain
time of night um
yeah i just wanted to strengthen that
really i would have any other any other
comment to
to anything you said thank you
thank you hazar not has one of the
object just got a question for the
applicant
yes okay you could ask it now and then
we'll hear the applicant's case so if
you ask it as a question
then we'll hear from the applicant and i
just would like to know
what um the applicant
would put in place to make sure that
these
disturbances are dealt with because
there
currently hasn't been anybody
as in a hotel you have the desk officer
um all night there doesn't seem to be
any
jurisdiction during the night for things
happening
and um
the thing is the pathfinder residents
pay their rates they are there 12 months
in the year
the people that come and go that's fine
they can make as much noise and as much
as we've seen in the rest of devon
they're as they like
and they don't pay team bridges rates
okay thank you yeah so could you answer
that as a question and then
following that if you move on to your
representations it it might all
be um encompassed in so i'll include an
answer to that
that's fine so um
if you don't mind i'll just read
something i've prepared
um good morning everyone i represent
finger glen golf hotel
as part of the management team and as
part of the family who are owners at
bingo glam
we are making this application to vary
our license so that our license
represents a typical license normally
obtained
by others in our industry of hotel
tourism and hospitality
it is key for us and keeping the
business sustainable
that we offer a venue for weddings and
functions which
does so much to support our main
business of gold
offering opening hours more suitable for
our guests and holidaymakers
will keep us on a level with competition
hotels and venues
due to the kobit 19 outbreak fingerprint
has already lost a great deal of revenue
through cancelled bookings
and we couldn't afford to lose out and
further business such as weddings and
functions
where potential customers have gone
elsewhere
for the opening hours to be more
favorable to
them bingo glenn has
always been since opening 30 years ago a
venue
for 14 years the lodges that are between
the clubhouse and our neighbours have
been in situ
over the years golfer's industry has
strived and has relied more and more and
generated through hotel functions and
hospitality
by extending the opening hours of the
clubhouse we have no intention of
creating disruption to our neighbours
all of our own lodges are in fact nearer
the clubhouse than
any neighbours and so creating any
nuisance would only be counterproductive
and would cause disturbance to our own
holiday makers
our nearest neighbor to the clubhouse is
150 metres to the east
of the clubhouse and i appreciate the
lodges are a lot nearer
to our neighbours we aren't actually
applying to change activity within those
lodges
they will still be governed by the laws
and the rules that we set out and
continue to set out in our rules
of conduct so contrary to
representations we actually believe that
will cause very little added disruption
to our neighbours
but we are fully prepared by prior
arrangement with the function organizers
and holiday makers
enforce the code of conduct and
occupation the code will be given to all
guests displayed in all lodges and
written within welcome packs to ensure
minimal disruption to
the neighbours and to maintain the
tranquil atmosphere
which fingal glenn strives to keep
now obviously in response to pat
alongside the code of conduct it you do
need
um to be able to report if that code
does
ever get broken and so we have
introduced a new telephone system
at finger glen where it has 24-hour
monitoring
of a voicemail and an email address and
that is directly to the managers and to
myself
so that any complaint that is made can
be picked up immediately
and it needs to be acted on there and
then or certainly
reporting that customer
or the target of that complaint the very
next morning
i want to be able to facilitate
any complaint and i i welcome any
complaint as we all do
mutually find a benefit in keeping
fingerprint
and the log cabins quiet and tranquil as
it's the type of accommodation we look
to offer
generally to our customers because most
of our customers are family
and golf breaks who seek out
a quiet peaceful break thank you
thank you so have any of the members got
questions for the applicant at the
moment
thank you marie um yeah that was
bishop bishop um on page 12
item f um it states i mean there's more
has been mentioned at the beginning
actually
um it says that most fridays and
saturdays we would close
at midnight this is just to allow for
seasonal weddings and functions both
days from 7 00 am
to 1 30 am with live music
i mean to me weddings and and functions
are going on all year round so
is it just that you're mainly looking
now for a possible tens
application do for covering this please
we stay seasonal because the wedding
season
typically is over the summer months um
and it's particularly weddings that
we're looking to accommodate
um a tens license i don't think
um would be satisfactory for what we
require
in that very limited to how many of
those tens licenses we can
request and the period of time that they
cover
um i think the limit is 15 actually for
how many you can have per year
um and uh 15 weddings a year
um is is you know it's it wouldn't be
sufficient to
to cover our entire wedding program
okay the other thing i was going to ask
um i see that you're saying
provision of late night refreshments
would require from 2300 hours to 2
o'clock
to 2 a.m i mean along with that
surely people are going to need drink as
well to go with it aren't they
well that particular part of the
application would be
so that we can accommodate only staying
guests
so uh just like most hotels um
guests who are staying in the
accommodation quite often have
um the option of a later night bar than
the general guest so it'd just be
somewhere where
we can provide that facility
but mostly it's good to stay yes not to
not to everybody okay
moving on now to page 14 l
um i see you're saying opening times
would be
be dependent on the time of year um
you say all all you are asking for
is regular errors are they any different
from what you are having now
and that you just want to you just want
the option to be able to
offer late later bar hours
to some functions whenever needed
it won't be it won't be a regular
occurrence although you say this
is that not possible is it going to be
every weekend
um well for the
for the late night every weekend well we
don't have the bookings for it
um we'd have to seek those out so
it would just be good to be able to have
that as a
as a way of securing a booking we we do
lose out on multiple bookings to other
venues because
we can't offer certain opening hours
it's just a shame to have to lose out on
an entire
wedding booking because
the option to be open an hour later
isn't available
if you were fortunate enough though that
could very near work out every weekend
couldn't it
i mean we know people need the business
but uh
when you think of the residents etc
it could it yeah it could yes but with
the
with the the code of conduct and the
regulations that we have on site
we do everything we can to to minimize
those
the interruption to the neighbors who
would actually
you know who are 150 meters from the
clubhouse but
but granted a lot closer to the cabbage
but those cabins would be
regulated by the code of conduct that
leads on to my next one
um again you you say all the rules will
be followed and making sure all
guests are safe and not causing any harm
or disruption to others
i see that nothing in here nothing has
been said
of the possibility of disturbance to
neighboring residents
i mean are you likely to be having a
warden or security on 24 7 at all i know
you mentioned about phone system but uh
are you having any other warden system
at all
uh monday to friday uh i'm not on site
on
saturdays and sundays we do have
somebody who could act on any phone call
and attend site which we already do
um which is a 24-hour emergency contact
that person could be on site seven days
a week
24 hours a day okay um
and then lastly picking up on what i
said to the objectors
um i understand there's been a history
of complaints
from boisterous noise and unruly
behavior
um and live music extremely loud i mean
how would you be able to come overcome
these issues some problems
i haven't had any complaints of that
nature
formally
but we would deal with those complaints
by by visiting site if it was a
if it was happening there and then and
we would close that down if it was
something that was happening in the
lodges
um it wouldn't be um something
which would happen in the clubhouse
because obviously the
the behaviors of all the guests would be
monitored by our staff
on site at the time okay thank you
council cruiser bradford do you have any
questions for the
applicant
no no actually chairman i think you've
covered the things that i was
concerned about okay thank you
so uh doctor yes would it be possible
marie
for me just to interject there and just
add a couple of
points please yes of course yeah of
course okay
okay thank you um i'd just like to um
point out that um any planning
application
for new lodges or anything to do with
the lodges has no bearings on
this application this is a variation for
the actual
um hotel itself and therefore has no
impact on the lodges or any
planning application um also um
i think councilman nutley you asked
about um
if things went on late into the night
there is a section in the report
that the police have asked the applicant
to include
in regards to having sia registered door
supervisors
based on whatever function they might be
having at the hotel
if they felt there was a need to be on
duty from 9 p.m so there is
also that option there as well and um
just to also add the late night
refreshment is just basically to serve
any food
um any food or snacks etc
um or soft drinks or cold drinks for
that time
thank you thank you derby
thanks for that comment debbie and i'll
just um reiterate
actually for members to remember that
there is a distinction between the
planning function of the council and the
licensing
function of a council and that it may be
possible
to condition planning applications your
concern today
is the application to vary the premises
license
um bearing in the four licensing
objectives in mind
and also the distinction here between
the application being for the actual
clubhouse itself
rather than sometimes the behavior that
seems to be happening within the
within the chalets um thank you
um have um the environmental health
officer got any further questions of the
applicant
sorry i was trying to get myself off
meat then
um yes um if i may um just got a few
questions just for max if that's all
right
um so um my first question was um
just in regards to the telephone system
the complaints procedure
um i appreciate that you've set that up
and that's
a very good way of um you know being
able to communicate with
your complainants and to keep that
rapport with residents as well
um is that currently in place is that
um it's actually being fitted tomorrow
and today the survey was done last week
uh to make sure that the um
the existing setup we had here was
applicable for it and it's
approved and done and the in station
starts today and tomorrow
and i'm more than happy for it to be a
condition on the on the
that is completed but certainly
already the email is set up and the
voicemail is set up by the end of today
but i'm more than happy to be a
condition in the license that is in
place at all times
okay so with that so is the
so for example if um a complainant with
a phone in
um would that be through the main line
and then that would get directed it
would be
it would be through the the main
landline which is you can find
on on any search directory and you'll be
able to phone into that
and leave a message on the voicemail
system which is monitored
24 7 by uh i could forgive me
if i could say bye
basically means i can from my mobile
telephone i can get any message left on
there
on the main landline and i can receive
it on my phone
as can any any other management team so
we if
a message comes through we can access
that message from anywhere
and then deal with it accordingly
brilliant thanks for that
um it was just just one more question
just in regards to the
um opening hours um so
i understand that currently on fridays
uh the current
um your current premises license on a
friday
permits you um to be open until half
midnight
and then on saturday until midnight um i
understand just from what you would
um uh having responded to counseling at
least
um questions in regards to um
the extension that you said that um
you know it'd only be for an hour past
that times four events but if it were to
go on until two o'clock
and you know my concern is that
um you know past that point um with
um members of that particular event
whether it be a wedding or
you know another sort of social event um
is that
um the hours would um
uh disrupt neighboring residents and
things like that
um because people wouldn't be um leaving
the site until around
you know past half two in the morning
and so that's just
one of my concerns really right okay
well
the people that would be leaving site
would be staying with us
because it would be guests that would be
staying on for the extra time
um and we'd obviously monitor how how
they got back to their accommodation
and or how they left the site um
we'd manage that in-house with measures
with staff
and have have it monitored so that
people left
appropriately and you know most most
events would finish up at our regular
time of midnight
and it's just the ones where
you know they might go on later just for
the people that are staying there
it's just an option to be able to offer
to say that you know if you have a whole
family that's staying with us for a
wedding they can stay on past the party
and just you know just mull over the
evening or
or what not whatever they choose to do
in that time but it won't be
you can see that the the application the
music stops well before
that time so the party will be over it's
just to play a way of
being able to leave slowly and not have
to leave her
you know on the strike at midnight we
could monitor that
within our own staff i don't know i
anticipate
thanks for that um i i think just
in terms of what you said about um the
recorded music
finishing well before um
you know the proposed closing times um
it does say until
well the live music sorry right okay
yes but the the recorded music is
anything from volume one
so it could just be background music
that we're licensed to play which is why
in the daytime as well um
recording music from 7am is so we're
licensed to
you know to hear music over the sound
system in the clubhouse as we're
not licensed to turn that on at the
moment until 10 o'clock i believe
okay thank you for that
thank you have
er the object has got any questions of
the applicant please
i haven't got any i don't know about pat
i'm i'm just very concerned about this
application
and i i just don't want to be a motive
about it but at the end of the day these
people have to live in these shallows
and to have any more disruption and
noise
that i mean they collect collect bugs of
gold caught the golf balls in their
in their gardens they're so close so
you know it's just and pathfinder was
there before the golf course
of course
obviously we in all aspects of
this application and although
not relevant the future applications
peacefulness
and tranquility of the site is something
we've always strived for would continue
to strive for
and not only that we're we're
actively seeking to make it that way
with
the code of conduct and the type of
wedding the type of hotel guest we're
looking to attract
so i want to give assurances
to the residents
living nearby
thank you um chair have any of the
members got any further questions for
any of the parties before we hear all
parties um just sum up
just a quick one of them i to the
applicant um the actual hotel itself
i mean just had a thought besides the
challenge how many guests can you
accommodate in the actual hotel uh in
the hotel we have
nine double bedrooms so up to 18 persons
thank you thank you thank you
thank you marie
thank you um so
jess is there anything else you want to
do by way of summary
just it's just a summing up or if you
feel you've said enough that's fine
um i don't think i've got anything else
no i think
most of the points have been uh covered
in terms of that
so yeah nothing else from me
sorry i was muted um
have the objectives anything they wish
to say just by way of final summary
i think i think all the points are
probably being covered
um adequately yeah we both yes we're
both of that
that position okay thank you very much
so um
the applicant you've just got a few
minutes now to um
summarize your representations thanks
thank you firstly i'd like to thank
everyone
who was attending this morning and who
has put some thought into our
application over the last few weeks
um i just want to reiterate again
that the applications are for the
fingerprint golf hotel clubhouse
and although they there are most of the
objections come from
uh concerns with the lodges uh we do
everything we can
to minimize the um
consequences of the application in the
clubhouse
causing any added issues
via the club the lodges afterwards um
and just as i said a moment ago that we
are doing everything we can to push
finger glenn as a golf course
um but we do have to for our own
sustainability um
occupy or keep these functions
at finger gang uh it's something we
can't do without
and it's something that we have to
consider moving forward
um to be able to facilitate the weddings
and events as best we can
but golf just in our name gold
fingerprint golf hotel we are a golf
course
and we want to continue being a quiet
tranquil environment which people want
to keep visiting
thank everyone for their time today
thank you very much for the summary um
licensing officer debbie
is there anything you feel any
additional comments that you wish to
make
no i think it's all been covered thank
you thank you debbie
um chairman if there's no further
information you feel you need are you
ready to retire
just thank you and i'll take my
colleagues or as well thank you
okay thank you um trisha beth made now
just
remind everybody of what's going to to
happen due to we're in the territory of
these virtual meetings
and it's all slightly still strange
thanks chris
yes thank you chair um just to say that
we're now
we're going to adjourn so we will stop
the live streaming
um for the members to enable
discussion of the application and then
when members have reached their decision
and we're
ready to announce that then we will
start the live streaming again
so for a short while we're going to be
offline
for members of the public watching and
the objectives and the applicants we
don't know how long i'm
sorry we can't give a time for that
hopefully
approximately around 20 minutes to half
an hour
maybe before so
we'll be reconvening then so i'll just
stop
stop live streaming take a few minutes
for it to